vamos es
posible sin duda resulta una
coincidencia difícil de entender que
existen tres fugas el mismo día en
gasoductos particularmente
es un gasoducto nuevo ni siquiera entrar
en la operación
dada las circunstancia tan compleja
política que existe en este momento y
que estaban ustedes describiendo Muy
bien pues me queda muy claro que el
hecho de que de pronto surjan estas
explosiones y estas fugas evidentes de
metano en medio del mar
denotan
digamos unas posibles acciones de Rusia
por presionar
a la región
eso es lo que le podría decir en este
sentido bueno porque estas explosiones y
la pérdida de este Preciado combustible
podría generar aún más estrés en el
mercado energético eso teniendo en
cuenta lo que ustedes ya nos decía que
el flujo en ambas vías estaba cortado o
inoperativo
en realidad yo pruebo más estrés en
términos políticos porque efectivamente
en términos del flujo del gas no hay
cambio el
Europa se ha tratado venir preparando
para el invierno que es donde vendrá la
presión importante y la ausencia del gas
ruso por lo menos para para Europa
del Oeste específicamente para Alemania
entonces creo que lo que la forma en que
se puede analizar este hecho es en
términos de posible depresiones
políticas digamos de la decisión de
Rusia de continuar presionando
eventualmente de involucrar a la otan
Pues de una manera más agresiva pero
desde el punto de vista energético no
hay ningún cambio para el suministro de
gas Europa muy bien y entre tanto cree
usted que esta noticia podría generar el
temor de ataques a infraestructuras
críticas sobre todo después es del ducto
que acaba de ser estrenado en Dinamarca
para conducir combustible desde Noruega
ese ese es un tema muy relevante en
general en una acción de este tipo no
hay duda alguna que la infraestructura
en materia energética resulta
estratégica para la seguridad integral
de un país esa señal si me parece
relevante si me parece que recoge los
riesgos digamos involucrados con una
posible con un posible Sabotaje y por lo
cual en ese sentido digamos
efectivamente hay razones
muy justificadas de la preocupación el
ataque a una infraestructura energética
pues es una decisión
posible y sin duda con con implicación
relevantes para cualquier país bueno y
ya para finalizar quisiera preguntarle
sobre su opinión de posibles peligros
ambientales para la región esta fuga
continuará una semana hasta que sea
seguro empezar a hacer las reparaciones
pertinentes Sí sí sin duda el metano que
es lo que se está jugando en este
momento es un gas de efecto invernadero
del probablemente el más poderoso que
existe esto representa no hay duda un
daño ecológico relevante para la vida
digamos subyacente a la región y
contribuye digamos a la presión en
materia del calentamiento global
esa es una realidad la fuga es
importante y desafortunadamente pues se
presenta en un contexto en donde el
mundo entero está cuestionando la
posibilidad de seguir avanzando la
transición en